there's a story in the news that's been
reported that that old people stick with
me old people nationwide are trying to
live longer they say they want to live
this is very very old people they want
to live just a little bit longer so they
can read the Muller report when it comes
out hey watch that's a real thing this
has been reported a bunch of places I
think they went out and they've talked
to a lot of old people they're like I
want to hang on
just cuz I've heard so much about this I
want to read them Muller report
I like that they'd be like well I would
just die otherwise yeah you know but I
want to read this report I'm what
Trump's been up to I thought this was
crazy when I read I was reading about
the city how that was crazy and then I
remembered my grandfather lived three
extra years just cuz he wanted to see
the Gilmore Girls finale I was like you
can go now grandpa you've had a good
life he's like no I want to see if Rory
gets bucked together with Logan watch
that last episode and went yeah yeah
that was crazy went right into the light
he hurts the light go to the light
what's that it was that it's fine it's
just depressing to me that now that
people used to have such great last
words like I love you Sun and now
people's last words gonna be I knew it
collusion there is a PTA
[Laughter]
yeah wish I had that effect on people
you know I wish I was I wish people were
saying like people's sons and grandsons
were saying you can go another like no I
can't
Conan's on it 11 Conan's can run Funches
yes he has a new format he wears casual
jackets
[Applause]